Speaker 1: All right, we're going to have a
very instructive segment here on the concept
of stochastic terrorism. Stochastic terrorism is
something we've talked about many times before.
The idea is that if you have a large enough
audience and you put out radical ideas,
you allude to drastic action or violence that
if your audience is big enough, it starts to
become statistically likely that someone in
that audience is going to take what you say
and turn it into real world violence. One example
is Glenn Beck. Years ago, on his old program,
right wing host Glenn Beck would constantly
be ranting about the Tides Foundation. The
Tides Foundation and his audience was big enough
that eventually he actually convinced the guy
to go and drive to the town's Tides Foundation
with the goal of shooting it up. The guy was
actually stopped. I believe it was by California
Highway Patrol on his way and said, Yeah,
Glenn Beck radicalized me. And that's why, you
know, we got to stop what these people are doing.
One such organization that is doing this in a in
a sense, is this organization Turning Point USA,
whose most prominent sort of spokesperson is a
guy named Charlie Kirk. Charlie Kirk does not
directly advocate for violence, and even in the
clip, I'm playing for you. He denounces someone
in the audience who talks about using guns to kill
these people. But what you have to understand is
when you run a group like this and you do event
after event with extremely radical ideas where
you are telling the audience, the Democrats, the
left, whatever, these are socialists, these are
communists, these are oppressors. These are all
these different things. These are all lies, by
the way, that are being told, of course, you are
going to start radicalizing people in the audience
who are eventually going to say, Well, I should
really do something about it. Some of those people
will do something about it by voting. Some of them
will do something about it by bullying people on
the internet. And unfortunately, some percentage
of the disproportionately gun owning people in the
following base of Charlie Kirk and Turning Point
USA may turn to violence. And that's exactly what
we have an example of right here. We are going
to play a clip of an audience member who loves
Charlie Kirk, who says, Hey, when can we use our
guns to kill these people? It's not a euphemism.
It's not a metaphor. He literally
is saying at a certain point,
like, when can we start shooting these
people? And what I want you to listen to
is when Charlie Kirk denounces it. He doesn't
denounce it because he's morally against shooting
political opponents. Maybe he is, but he doesn't
say it. He denounces it because he says that would
be playing into what the left wants, and it would
give them justification to be even more radical.
That's why Charlie Kirk denounces it.
Look, this is everything that is wrong
with the American right wing right now.
Let's take a listen. Let's take a look.
Speaker 4: Ready. Yeah, you're brave, you're
brave for what you say and the fact that you
see up there and say, and I appreciate,
I think we all appreciate it actually,
because there's not a lot of people so big.
Speaker 1: Charlie Kirk fan calling him brave.
What Charlie Kirk does and
says is just it's silly pablum,
but this guy says it's brave, okay,
Speaker 4: that I have the balls to
do it, but I want to ask you something a little
bit out of the ordinary. So prepare yourself.
At this point, we're living under
a corporate and medical fascism.
Speaker 1: Now that's not. That's not true.
Speaker 4: OK, let's go. This is tyranny.
When do we get to use the guns?
No, and I'm not. That's not a joke.
Speaker 1: Now, a lot of the crowd cheers,
and this guy says it's not a
metaphor. He's saying it, literally.
Speaker 4: OK, I'm not saying
it like that. I mean, literally,
where's the line, right? Elections? Are they going
to steal? Before we kill these people? So no,
I know home. I'm holed up in that. Now I'm
going to denounce them and tell you why.
Speaker 1: OK, so I'm going to denounce
that and I'm going to tell you why. Tell us,
Charlie. Is it because it's wrong to do that
Speaker 4: because you're playing into all
their plans?
Speaker 1:
No. Killing them with guns would play right
into their plans, so we shouldn't do that.
What about it being completely
wrong and immoral and criminal? No,
no. It would play into their hands,
Speaker 4: and they're trying to make you do this,
that's OK. Hear me out. You started with the
compliments or at least give me a little bit.
They are trying to provoke you and everyone
here they are trying to make you do something
that will be violence that will justify a takeover
of your freedoms and liberties that we have never
seen. We are close to have human. We are close
to have momentum to be able to get this country
back on a trajectory using the peaceful means
that we have at us. So to answer your question,
and I just think it's, you know, overly blunt,
we have to be the ones that do not play into the
violent aims and ambitions of the other side. They
fear. Let me say this very clearly they fear this.
Speaker 1: This is a this is a verbal
trapeze artist. It's a contortion
Speaker 4: holding the line with self-control and
discipline, taking over school board meetings.
They're the ones that are willing to use federal
force against us. And I know that people get fired
up. We are living under fascism. We are living
under this tyranny. No, we're not for a second
that they're not wanting you to all of a sudden
get that next level where they're going to say,
OK, we need Patriot Act 2.0. If you think that
you know Waco is bad, what do you see what they
want to do next? What I'm saying is that we have a
very fragile balance right now at our current time
where we must exhaust every single peaceful
means possible. I will say this Idaho has not
even started to exercise the peaceful
means of state sovereignty against the
federal government. Not even close. I'll give
you five things Idaho could do right now.
The governor of Idaho could sign an executive.
Speaker 1: OK, so Charlie Kirk is clearly smart
enough not to encourage. He knows if he goes,
You know what? You're right. We should just go
and kill these people with guns. Let's kill our
political opponents with guns. He has no choice
but to denounce it, which he did, and to the
extent that he deserves credit for that, OK?
He denounced it. But he's not saying don't go and
kill people with guns because it's morally wrong.
He's not saying don't go and kill people with
guns, because that's actually the problem in
the United States that, you know, I talk about. We
have a unique cultural problem in the U.S., where
there are people that see guns as a solution to
political problems and to interpersonal problems.
This guy is the perfect example, he's saying.
Listen, they stole an election, which they didn't.
We're now under fascism, which we're not.
So we should go and we should solve those
problems by killing people. Shoot him dead
with guns. This isn't. This is the prototypical
American that embodies the cultural problem we
have with guns in the United States. Charlie
is not saying that's not what gun should be used
for. He's not saying it's morally wrong. He's not
saying that's criminal. He's just saying it would
backfire. It would play into it would justify them
becoming even more fascistic, in fact.
Charlie agrees with the guy and saying,
We are living under fascism. So even what the
guy identifies as a problem Charlie agrees with
and says, we are living under fascism. But the
problem is if we go out and kill them with guns,
not that it's wrong. Not that it's immoral. It
it'll just justify even more of their fascism. Now
there's another interpretation of Charlie Kirk's
answer and this this one is the cynical one.
This is the Griveaux interpretation, which
is Charlie Kirk doesn't really believe any
of what he's selling. OK. He doesn't really
want to change anything. He doesn't want
real action. He doesn't want resolution. He wants
to be perpetually on the edge of boiling over
and continue holding these events so that
the business model perpetuates itself. And
nothing really like if you really solve the
problem, right? Whatever, whatever means you use,
as he says, no, no, no, no, we're going to we're
going to go to the school boards and then we're
going to do this. We're going to do that, then
we're going to solve it. Well, then there's no
more Turning Point USA. There's no more angry
people going to these events and saying we got to
fix the fascism. If you fix the fascism, there's
no more people who will show up and say, Charlie,
help us fix the fascism because you've dealt with
it. So the other cynical interpretation of Charlie
denouncing the shooting people dead with guns
is now, but then that'll hurt my events. But
the problem is people hear there is fascism and
they don't hear Charlie say it's wrong to shoot
people. They just hear him say, Well, it would.
It wouldn't be productive towards our cause.
And then it has that sarcastic terrorist
effect and think about it. This guy who
asked the question said he thinks Charlie Kirk
is smart and he thinks Charlie Kirk is brave
and he wants to shoot his political opponents over
non-existent medical fascism and not a nonexistent
election theft. And he's not being told that it's
wrong. He's just being told it wouldn't be good
strategy. Well, he might just disagree on strategy
or maybe someone else in the audience does. Now,
probably the FBI should have a look at the guy
who asked the question, Does that guy own guns?
I would assume almost certainly, yes. What's
going on with him emotionally? Is he stable? Is
he likely to do something? That's someone who,
in all seriousness, should be on the radar of
authorities, of law enforcement authorities when
they tell you what they want to do. We should
listen to them, and this guy is telling us exactly
what he wants to do. He wants to solve problems.
He wrongly believes to exist like that of a
stolen election or medical fascism by shooting
people dead. Law enforcement should listen
to that, and then they should investigate it.